how about welcome back to the lobby did
you know this is a new divinity game at
kevin van or does that's why he's here
to talk to us all about it well hello
divinity original same yes it's a much
better name than divine divinity not
really irked me that it is i wasn't
known isn't that still the name of like
a power in that game though that's all
right by yourself against divine
divinity hey it's been a while since I
played the original divine of it he's
been I was like Cheerios for years but
you can play it on steam now which is
good you can now get Devon while you
could get before on GOG as well but you
can get you like it divine divinity had
a sequel beyond divinity yeah and then
there's a bunch of yeah that well yeah
and in divinity two came out and that
was a different kind of game a third
person yeah sort of action RPG original
sin is different as well because it's
that they're kind of leaning into the
yeah bro sounds completely different and
you play is two different people as well
yeah at one time so so Chris is 0
Chris's get me wrong look at that it
also know we're really good so for folks
who don't know anything about this Kevin
hardly what type of game is divinity
retired so this is a this is an
isometric view role-playing game so at
first you know at first blush you might
think hey this looks a whole lot like
Diablo but it's not actually like I
brought only think it looks a lot like
Diablo shut up g off shush your pedantic
and mouth yes Kevin so so you start with
your two adventurers and this is very
very meaning of the game i'm g on this
but because of where I am in the game I
suspect it will be really boring yes to
show off so this is actually the
beginning so at first blush yeah it
looks a little bit like it it might be
like a Diablo kind of thing or Diablo or
our job George oh but instead it's it's
a lot more like temple of elemental evil
if you ever played that so you get the
top-down thing but once combat starts
what's it doing you it actually goes
turn base ok and I'm hoping to show you
that but first I'm gonna come over here
pick up a LuthorCorp roll maybe pick up
a shell got those do you always because
you've got the warrior and then your
mystic which is kind of like your healer
yeah you always control the warrior you
can control either one okay so even
either one has different you know
different socialization skills so it's
not like income you know in conversation
it's not just defaulting yeah you know
it's whoever you're controlling at the
time you can switch between them and
there are reasons to switch between them
so for example my which she can talk to
she can talk to animals so sometimes
there's a reason to switch over so if
you click on it with the dude he's like
what do you ask me to talk to his animal
for I can talk to animals yeah there's
like meow all right does he say meow and
then it's like God nothing well no he
doesn't say meow but she it's actually
interesting because there's one part
towards the beginning name where you're
talking the wizard there we go so here's
battle so as soon as battle initiate you
get it you get into a turn-based deal
god be with you master turn-based yes
all right is it all right so they're
running in their initiator running
there's gonna be one guy that's left if
i recall correctly he's gonna do a
summon skeletons golems and boom close
there you go or so all the combat is
turtle so the combat is all turn-based
although you can do things that are sort
of combat oriented even when you're not
in combat like heal each other or attack
doors and things like that so fight is
beginning and it tells you can control
and find out attributes over these
things so right now you know it starts
with my which gets the first turn so
she's got a lot of different things that
she can do it's nice you start with like
a good variety of spells it's not like
blah you know like a lot of RPGs you
being like OMG one damn so the first of
ranged attack and then I can learn area
too is I am going to summon some I our
own skeleton i'm gonna summon spider Oh
sick so the first thing that happens is
she's like oh gross there's a gross
spider for you I it looks really good
like yeah yeah the game just very
good-looking already and now she
preserves to action points hurt her
she's done moving on to the spiders turn
so I'm just gonna go after the summit
ouch I love that animation like crazy
you at the twitch on the twitch at once
down to him I had the switch shot wants
to know how much that ball physics is in
this game there is a
axum Utley no ball that is that's really
disappointing well you know we have to
have a diverse show here Danny we have
to have it this disappears to Iraq no
files testa files we already appear
appealed to the comes first segment and
then later on you know what Warcraft so
let's uh let's do some other magic let's
do this sort of magic missile here as
show be 89 asks do you have a main
character a bunch of characters these
are the only two characters you actually
play us right you don't use the eyes you
can add more characters to your party
you'll eventually come across people
like you know hench people that you can
add to your party why not they're all
fully controllable they all have their
own inventories and so on and so forth
two at a time always so no not to it's
alright as you get more okay so you can
up to you know I hope to water I I don't
know I want to say it's probably for but
I don't no don't don't answer they all
have the dialogue options you were
talking about earlier yeah you always
have yeah I think exactly you always get
the dialogue so sorry i get i get
distracted easily we're asking you a lot
of questions cuz i know there's some
dialogue stuff coming off that was a
really playing close magic shot we got
there Kevin uh I like how the magic how
it's like snakes it's not just a
straight line arrow yeah it's really
moves its way in there so it's
interesting as I played some of this
game when it was an alpha but I did not
actually play you know any of the any of
the later stuff after the ALPHAN like
January this was Kickstarter right yes
was kick-started they got over a million
I think and they asked they asked for
about four hundred thousand I said and
what they did is they made it really
what seems to be a really good game so
far I'm still early times obviously I'm
beyond this early time again this is the
this is basically the the introduction
stuff but things get really really
interested so so this is where you can
like oh I can attack this but you have
to be really careful when you choose to
attack stuff in the environment because
your your stuff takes takes damage okay
your weapons your weapons take damage or
so then you should be used it has been
really fast especially if your be very
careful with the especially if you're
like a row using
daggers or something those things can
break really fast at Bob man idiot asks
is there a co-op mode Ernest oh yeah no
yeah you can totally go up and it has
really interesting conversation things
that you can do hopefully I'll get a
chance to show you that just in the
single player bit because there's
there's actually a rock pit yeah you can
move stuff around this looks a little
silly visually horsepower I like it but
that's Kevin Adam does that lead to any
kind of I mean removing an obstacle is
one thing but does that leads at the end
of exploration totally totally in combat
you can use that stuff like if there's a
barrel oil then I can throw that on the
floor and spread oil and then i can and
then i can throw a candle on top of it
and set it aflame and you'll actually i
think you're actually gonna see that
soon so there's apparently a mine ahead
so i have to come up here i cants there
it is a completely unrelated at this
game is made by Larry and of course
you've made all the at divinity games
and they're located in Belgium so just
you know yeah totally in el djem I'll
Jim yep I hear that's a-ok nation
alright people with bad opinions about
stuff no whoops that did not seem to be
a real so that if that was a slide that
I I know you're on fire I meant to cast
a spell with her and I failed I wasn't
thinking ditches collaborative with used
I did that was pretty embarrassing yeah
G winners asks is there friendly fire
did we just answer that question yes
there is friendly fire for sure yes
absolutely yeah I would drop that scroll
in there surprised you managed to
deflect that damage that was a close one
and if you don't want you can do
something like if you don't want them to
stay together like that you can if you
want to control them individually you
can just drag their their portraits
apart like that and then i will say sell
it right yeah and you're gonna have our
can you go solving anywhere in the world
oh really yep wow ok you can be
completely separate that's especially
handy in coop if you want to separate
with with your you know from your from
your partner and go and do different
things what have you thought of it will
do that what have you thought about the
story so far affinities asking is the
story as well thought ID as right now
I'm just vin wrong about the the story
like it's just whatever you know it's
sort of like oh you're
you're going to the village and the
wizard they're summoned you and you have
to solve a murderer kind of thing and
that's that's in the main story that's
all I'm doing right now because I'm
really distracted by the sudden glut of
things that I get to do and there's a
lot of exploration because this is not a
game that holds your hand this is not a
game that sometimes a little too it
expects you a little little too much out
of you to figure out how stuff worked
like how the weapon damage worked and
how to how to repair it ah it took me
you want a little while to figure out
okay actually how to how to do some of
that stuff and you were saying earlier
like the characters you find that there
is no in terms of customization before
you get them can you make your own
characters or is it can you customize
your just one sorry I know only the two
at the beginning the two that you make
at the beginning are the only ones that
you can customize as far as I know the
rest of them are all just in-game
characters you kind of run into exact so
far exactly and then there are low diets
and gear and stuff like that like
inventory wisest or what you can do yep
yep there's here's a huge inventory and
you get between characters and if you
need one character to have another thing
you actually have to switch it between
the two Sardesai to get was it you know
his name is Roger get Ron original Hugh
inventory so right now it is really
great can you name him Hugh if you want
you can yes right I I went with the
default names which your router can
Scarlett but you can use whatever you
want and in this case I need to get past
that door you go into the skills and
talents were there as well what's in
there oh yeah yeah plus we go so I over
here we've got so here just the regular
is this all the regular stuff but if I
move over here you've got different
weapon abilities defensive ability
skills all of your stuff under
personality like salam and all and when
you make decisions you can because
you're you're too nasty of seeds yeah
nasty deeds which would be locked like
not murdering people and then there are
talents like this that eventually you
get talent points like right now / ouch
and which means he gets to perform
additional attacks of opportunity this
guy gets a you know gets maximum action
two points when his health is low what's
escapist do you write APIs op-eds
it's it just turns you into Yahtzee oh
yeah escapist allows you to flee combat
even when enemies are right next to you
what about far out man I gotta go search
for this is the range of spells and
Scrolls by 2 meters so you get a little
a little extra there so at this point I
need to I should've been paying
attention i'm going to need to do
something with this door probably bash
it it's coming back door I so given that
that land mine earlier I mean this sort
of seems like it's a high fantasy kind
of setting but land mine isn't exactly
like swords and sorcery type domain no
sir like does it sort of cast the net
wide in terms of what kind of gear and
what kind of world this is like how much
is as technology you know in the in a
more modern sense part of this it does
have some elements of things that you
might more associate with like you know
kind of steampunk whatever and it
teaches you to quick save so i might as
well just do what it says it's worked in
case and but it does cast it's not a
little bit why but it's mostly you know
Tolkien esque fantasy so here's an issue
where it's like okay what do I do here
I've got I've got all this fire and I
have to pass well just so happens
there's a rain scroll over here so I'm
gonna pick up the ring well hello stick
that down oops I missed add that down
here and now I'm gonna cast the rain on
top and this this comes I believe the
term is make it rain so I mean he's not
a strip club Chris so for example if I'm
in combat and I'm on fire I could do
this you know too or if you're fighting
some efreet would that like damage them
maybe yeah and you see over here just in
case there were water barrels I could
have just thrown it on there if I had
enough strength in this case you can't
use those ones combat a started i'm
guessing no you can use all that stuff
in common we can still move stuff around
you can still fire arrows stuff and
attack things in the environment and
stuff yeah totally that's cool
oppression and x 8 05 asks will this be
on steam this is already on Steve
already on yesterday I think yeah it was
launched yeah yesterday was official
launch and the thing is that oh I can
sit down
see some sweet sitting down 3999 this is
almost as you inhale schatz na mo chat
just yet although we we will hopefully
chat soon I just thought that world's
like disappearing as the camera moves in
this is pretty good that's pretty great
yeah I'm into value like that effect
yeah I'm into this so in this case it's
like oh I need to unlock a door so i
guess i'll just try some nasty deeds on
it try some nasty deeds we know I like
those nasty you don't you level up your
nasty deeds can you like perform them at
a greatly reduced cost what do you mean
reduced cost like you have to like it if
stuff normally is expensive can you do
them dirt cheap for a while Oh Jonah got
it that's pretty good how much have you
played it is so far cuddly cat jokes I
am like I'm like maybe six hours in or
something like that but I feel like I've
done nothing I'm seriously at the point
where I feel like nothing has happened
so because the world is faster because
you find it tedious because its vast and
there's a lot to do and in a few cases
because the game doesn't necessarily
help help you figure out stuff so
there's a lot of time spent like just
hey how do i how do I do this what does
this do yes how do I you know what do
these what are these people gonna say
okay so now what are you finding not
entertaining are you finding a TV you
turn into a CEO with entertaining it's
flush stealth mode so here's telephone
now when you go into stealth mode you
automatically leave your partner but
with apologies to solid snake and here's
a fun thing I'm just gonna throw some
candles on them okay nice yeah they
because see they've got they've got oil
on the ground and so I'm gonna catch
them on fire why they seem pretty non
perturbed by the time they're on fire
right now mommy's man there's no I'm
gonna come over here and see if I can if
I can do more of that Oh nope alright so
I'm coming back coming back coming back
does it is really delayed does it say
the the rock on the side of that the
orange the gray rock alright so here we
go I'm gonna I'm gonna do some summoning
I'm just gonna do a bunch of summoning
what's summon what kind of stuff can you
summon she already had a spider out what
our type of animals well there's this
here a skeleton I had a scroll so you
can use anybody can use a scroll there
you don't have to have learned to spell
in advance or anything so she's done now
here comes my fighter so let's do this
oh he's got a summit in here too i do it
yeah some one woman wolf so that's some
in the wolf firewall oh my goodness an
amazing say bye oh cool wolf was
incredible yeah like thou yeah it's
pretty great oh really yeah and now my
summon has his turn but he's not gonna
be able to quite get there I have enough
action points though where he can attack
this dude yeah in this rage she's doofus
he missed you gallatin oh you got you
there oh gosh we're coming out a second
guy all right now we've got her let's
get a spider in on the act yeah horrible
spider demon
that makes a bit more sense because
you're in a cave earlier it was a bit
weird we just kind of I don't know that
I kind of like it I like an airdrop
spider yeah pretty much pretty much and
like you read on all right Wolf's turn
let's see what the wolf's got up is yo F
dot do it up to Wolf's have sleeves BAM
engagingly leading but it's okay because
he's dead now right take that mummy I
don't I can't go over there so let's
kind of come up with I find most people
are immune to beating once they've died
so Kevin that the turn based stuff here
doesn't take place on a hex grid or
anything like that do you find you run
into any kind of path finding or like
like resource you know cuz like every
move every space you move takes up you
know it'll take up some points to move
do you find that all that sort of
balances out you can get a good sense of
how it's like the logic is sound and and
predictable and so you think you can
move somewhere you can move there do you
get a good so no totally totally it
works there's there's a little bit of
this issue where it's like how close can
I get before fight fighting starts um
that kind of thing where you ishy eight
the term base right segment exactly but
once you one should kind of get used to
that you can kind of you use you're
still using the environment to how you
kind of want to use it for yourself you
just got to pay attention to what you
see what's happening around you cool and
then all it all sort of works out on its
own it's it's pretty easy to pick up on
Evan thank you very much coming on oh my
god you're done I got one more question
for you one single hood that I just want
to keep playing the same rule but you
can pick it up for themselves it's on
Steam right now yeah totally and when is
our review going up who knows it's I
guess it's about I just started it we
didn't get advance code of the final
version so i got i got started with
everybody else gets started so as soon
as I'm it's done when it's done it's
like a blizzard game cool I got one
final question because it was something
i was wondering as well evermind a th in
K spot shot asks does the game scale
with your level or do you do much
grinding as far as I know the game is
not scaled with your level okay you're
not going out there and it's this is not
oblivion or whatever you know it's like
if something's high-powered you go out
there and you face it you're screwed
excellent you know and there are places
where you can get into really really big
trouble you can fight anything you want
to fight if you want to or steal
anything that you want to steal people
will not be happy with you they will
attack you
you can attack different you know
different mission givers so that you
know their their side missions are now
gone forever you can you know there's
loud and are you good reason to do that
though I feel like we always want the
mission on if a guy looks at you wrong
there's a good human mother a lot of
this stuff the missions just there's so
many different ways of completing them
like the fact that I can talk to animals
has made certain instances quite
different than if I couldn't like I get
clues and I can suddenly like salt I've
consulted my murder again I won't talk
to animals if they play these care if
they play a wish they'd charms with that
yeah or if eventually you choose that
when you get the opportunity